my favorite team has been struggling a
little bit the New England Patriots are
one in two and there was some
controversy before their Sunday night
game this week when it was revealed by
ESPN's Adam Schefter that Rob Gronkowski
considered retirement during the
offseason and when the Patriots were
ready to trade him to the Detroit Lions
that's when he said no I'm not gonna
play for a Detroit I'll retire instead
of playing for them I'm only gonna play
with Tom Brady they decided not to do it
they caught Belichick just stood down
and they ended up keeping Robin cast so
he's threatened to retire they said
we're gonna trade you he said if you
trade me all the tire and they said okay
we'll keep you and he said okay I'll
play ya he's an idiot I mean it worked
it actually is a player that kind of
stared down Bill Belichick mate everyone
from that he refused to talk to the
Lions he refused to say anything he
ended up going to talk with Bill
Belichick and basically said I'm dead
serious my back doesn't matter I'm not
moving to Detroit to play with you know
play in that city I'm only playing with
Tom Brady and the Patriots were like all
right we respect that we'll keep you I
mean I might be the only person in
America willing to go out in line and
say this but Rob Gronkowski could take
bail Chuck in a fight I think that's
fair the guy threatened to retire he's
going to eventually retire fact I say
the Patriots dumped him now cut him
don't even see what you can get for him
just cut him bring back Aaron Hernandez
he's rested next on the news docket is
one of my favorite stories to come
across the pike in a long time I don't
know if you're familiar with this I
don't normally want to talk too much
about just video stories where we're
like talking about a video that we've
seen but this one is too good to resist
chip the Buffalo the Colorado mascot for
their football team fired a t-shirt gun
last week that blasted his dick in balls
according to this report he crumpled
into a heap
and was just writhing on the ground in
pain for a while and then was carted off
the field by medical personnel a lot of
things to love about this story can we
hear the clip from the mascot shooting
himself okay I'll fess up that is just
the whale hitting the dumpster again
yeah of them both sounding the same was
so funny to me that in our
pre-production meeting I insisted on it
and let's hear it again I'm delighted by
it actually Erika this time play the
actual sound play the actual sound of
the mascot shoot himself it gets funnier
look as coming from someone who has hurt
a lot of people with the t-shirt cannon
I thought this was just amazing because
the t-shirt cannons a powerful tool that
no one really understands how it works
now I'm sure people have it's backfired
before when people hurt themselves
I know if the Buffalo had it upside down
or if it just backfired I think I think
he just had it that's my interpretation
as it was just in Reverse and he shot it
off into his when he goes to the ground
it's up there with do you remember when
they lowered the the mascot from the
rafters in basketball and it looked it
was a raptor it was like a coyote who
was just looked like he was just hanging
dead like he had been he's passed out
cold and they lowered his body to the
ground
amazing the Japanese thing where the
Frog mascot freaks out in the middle of
the field and they carry him off
honestly you're still in the cost I like
that you think everyone has an excitin
cyclope deck you know knowledge of
mascot injuries that they can just
recall at any moment most people don't
remember this for the rest of anyone
who's anyone knows exactly what I'm
talking about I really like when they
refuse to take the helmet off the mascot
even though they're in medical trouble
that they put them on the cart fully
clothed and dragged them out and then
had to have him come back out and beg no
he's okay he's not okay alright he went
down hard
that's a different guy in the costume
don't think I'm an idiot I love that
this was captured from so many angles
because who was filming
the mascot firing a t-shirt hitting the
Buffalo I don't know well I don't know
what they thought the payoff for that
would be but they got some but it's like
we live in a police state now and I'll
tell you what if this is what we get out
of it I'm all for it
I'm all for giving up my freedoms I'm
all for giving up chip the Buffalo that
was one of the funniest things I've ever
seen and I'm just sad we had to wait so
long to get to a kids play the clip one
more time
[Music]
you